[Applaus]
[Musik]
im ausland ob zu hause ein flop so
scheint es gerade us präsident joe biden
zu stellen viele länder haben die us
aussenpolitik seitigen ukraine krieg
zwar schätzen gelernt vor allem wenn sie
nachbarn haben wie china oder russland
und auch wir haben die derzeitige
außenpolitik der usa und joe biden es
oft gelobt doch ganz anders sieht es
beim eigenen wahl volk aus die
popularität beiden es befindet sich seit
monaten im sinkflug die unzufriedenheit
mit seiner arbeit als präsident erreicht
sogar neue rekordwerte wir haben die
ergebnisse der aktuellen umfragen mal
zusammengetragen mitte juli 2022 wollten
laut einigen umfragen sage und schreibe
71 prozent der wahlberechtigten nicht
dass beiden erneut kandidiert sogar bei
den demokraten waren knapp über die
hälfte gegen eine erneute kandidatur
noch schlimmer für beiden wird es bei
jungen demokraten zwischen 18 und 29
jahren 94 prozent von ihnen wollen dass
opa joe in rente geht also fast alle
präsident bei mir steht vor einem
desaster bei jungen wählern was bei den
demokraten die befürchtung verstärkt
dass sie eine ganze generation verlieren
wenn er sein ansehen bei der generation
sie nicht verbessert und das ist noch
nicht alles sagt beiden regiert geht es
bergab mit der zustimmung und das
stärker als bei anderen us präsidenten
der durchschnitte umfragewerte bei
realclearpolitics.com zeigt einen
abwärtstrend von 20 prozentpunkten seit
amtsantritt bis mitte juli mit der
august waren es zwar nur noch minus 15
prozentpunkte doch das ist eher ein
strohfeuer als eine echte trendwende
denn noch immer sind 54 prozent der amis
mitte arbeit ihres präsidenten
unzufrieden und nur 41 prozent zufrieden
[Musik]
eine solch starke unbeliebtheit ist auch
ein negativrekord unter us präsidenten
die das renommierte
meinungsforschungsinstitut gallup
köstlichen meldete kein präsident seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg hatte nach
anderthalb jahren amtszeit schlechtere
zustimmungswerte als beiden selbst trump
oder dort stabil bush nicht aber warum
bewerten die amerikaner ihren
derzeitigen präsidenten so schlecht
trotz des unrühmlichen abzugs des
westens aus afghanistan los ist auch
außenpolitisch ganz gut verbreiten steam
mitauslöser ändern die blinken und
verteidigungsminister lloyd austin und
wir reden hier von wirklich großen
erfolgen die usa führen den westens zu
gering an bei der unterstützung der
ukraine im krieg gegen russland unter
angriffs 1 führung ist am besten
zusammen gerückt und hat durch
sanktionen und waffenlieferungen röslers
pläne zur eroberung der ukraine zum
scheitern gebracht und die russen auch
militärisch erheblich geschwächt und
während von der einst zweitstärksten
armee der welt nur noch ein schatten
ihrer selbst übrig geblieben ist läuft
im gegensatz dazu die nato zu ihrer
topform auf wie lange nicht mehr
washington konnte die militärallianz
wieder zu einem festen block zusammen
schmieden und mit schweden und finnland
kommen zwei starke länder hinzu unter
trump erschienen die transatlantischen
beziehungen noch wie eine art ehekrise
die kurz vor der scheidung steht heute
hat man sich nach dem schock des ukraine
kriegs wieder zusammengerauft und die
usa sind die unumstrittene führungsmacht
eines neuen westens ähnlich gut läuft es
in asien hier vorne die usa mit großem
erfolg schlagkräftig allianzen um chinas
einfluss einzudämmen vor allem mit den
einst verfeindeten staaten südkorea und
japan dazu haben wir schon vor kurzem
ein video gemacht dass ich euch
verlinken werde erwähnt seien an dieser
stelle auch die stichworte august die
militärallianz zwischen den usa england
und australien oder das quad bündnis der
usa mit indien australien und japan und
das indopazifischen wirtschaftsabkommen
auf jeden fall punktet die aktuelle
beiden regierung auch den teilwahlen
militärischer beistand aus den usa gilt
den teil lesen das hat im falle einer
chinesischen adressierung als sicher und
auch wirtschaftlich dann die beziehungen
intensiver zwischen amerika und dem
chip-sektor so wichtigen treffer seht
her
usa und taiwan goldene gespräche zur
stärkung der wirtschaftsbeziehungen
führen und wie in ostasien läuft das
spiel auch im nahen osten
dort sind vielleicht die beziehungen zu
saudi arabien offen gesagt etwas
schlechter aber das hält man amerika
nicht davon ab neue allianzen zu bilden
so unterstützt beides regierung die
schaffung einer neuen militärallianz
mehrere arabische länder und auch israel
ist eine arabische nato sozusagen und
auch dazu verlinkt ich euch ein video
das vor kurzem herausgebracht haben
mit anderen worten präsenz und einfluss
der usa auf unserem planeten sind
derzeit so groß wie lange nicht mehr
zumindest aus westlicher sicht ist das
ein erfolg amerikanische außen und
sicherheitspolitik also fast volle
punktzahl wenn man joe biden nach außen
politischen kategorien bewerten wenn das
aber tut der typische amerikanische
wähler eben nicht es hagelt schlechte
noten für den präsidenten bei der
derzeitigen stimmungslage ist wenn
wiederwahl unwahrscheinlich und bei den
midterm elections im herbst droht den
demokraten eine herbe schlappe wie aber
ist diese massive ablehnung zu erklären
hat es vielleicht etwas mit den vielen
peinlichen kann zu tun die sich beiden
immer wieder leistet
[Musik]
wie zb in diesem video nur er sagte das
erträgt habe
das weiße haus hat sofort dementiert
beiden habe keinen krebs hat sich vor
amtsantritt lediglich eine verdächtige
hautstellen entfernen lassen warum ein
präsent sprach blieb unklar wegen der
aktive aussetzen versprecher hat er von
seinem widersacher donald trump den
beinamen sleepy dog bekommen und das
schon während des wahlkampfs vor zwei
jahren das mag nicht sehr nett sein
vielleicht sogar gemein doch die
geistigen und rhetorischen aussetzer
sind real und für die weltöffentlichkeit
offensichtlich andererseits joe biden
ist alt ganze 79 jahre und er wird im
november 80 man kann ist wähler nicht
verdenken wenn sie diesen mann schlicht
zu alt halten um der präsident der us-
ok zu sein doch es gibt noch einen
weiteren viel wichtigeren grund lieber
visuelle politik zuschauer joe biden
kommt mit seiner wirtschaftspolitik gar
nicht gut bei den amis an
dabei handelt es sich nicht um eine
fehlwahrnehmung aus unzufriedenheit
beides wirtschaftspolitik ist ganz
objektiv gesehen gescheitert weil viel
versprochen aber wenig geliefert wurde
denn wie vollmundig waren die
ankündigungen beiden oremex sollte
erneuerung oder eine 180 grad wende in
der wirtschaft stellen es sollte ein für
alle mal vorbei sein mit dem seit der
reagan ära herrschenden trend des
angeblichen minimal starts des dem und
unregulierten amerikas mit niedrigen
steuern ja als ob das wirklich noch der
realität entsprechen würde bild bag
batteries der schöne slogan unter dem
man die infrastruktur in amerika
sanieren und ausbauen wollte beides
umfeld tollte in den dimensionen des new
deals aus der roosevelt er einen
aufbruch aus einer großen depression
[Musik]
heute so sprach beiden während des
wahlkampfs davon die gewerkschaften zu
stärken der klimawandel sollte bekämpft
werden studenten sollten die schulden
gestrichen werden und migration wieder
in geordneten bahnen verlaufen für den
wiederaufbau der infrastruktur sollten
investitionen angekurbelt werden private
investitionen aber vor allem auch wissen
wieviel geld er sollte es geben eben ein
riesiges die der opfer programm nach art
des legendären jugend deal doch seither
ist ist eher still geworden in vielen
fällen sind die projekte ins stocken
geraten ist passiert einfach nichts mehr
das problem ist der wirtschaftsmotor der
usa stottert der zeit gewaltig seht euch
diese schlagzeilen die us inflation
erreichte im juni mit 9,1 prozent ein
neues 40 jahre hoch die zahlen zeigen
dass die us wirtschaft auf eine
rezession zumindest zusteuert also ist
beiden fein raus nach dem motto es wirkt
halt nicht gerade wegen der globalen
wirtschaftskrise des normalen auf und ab
der marktwirtschaft nein so einfach ist
es nicht in diesem video wollen euch
genau erklären was bei den beiden mx
alles schief läuft und dass die
derzeitige lage auch eine folge von
falscher wirtschaftspolitik ist und am
ende werde tier genau verstehen wieso
sleepy georges bataille ökonomische
entscheidungen auch einen starken effekt
auf die gesamte weltwirtschaft inklusive
europas haben also schnallt euch an der
legen sofort los nach einem kurzen da
welchen weiß man es aus tollen sponsors
of sharjah libyen ist ein wirklich
sicheres vpn welches keinerlei
verbindungsdaten mit lockt natürlich
kann ein virtual private network vpn
einen nicht vor allen gefahren schützen
die ihnen es lauern man muss nach wie
vor umsicht walten lassen und wissen was
man tut aber es stellt hierfür einen
werkzeug mit gleich mehreren vorteilen
da zu einer erschwerten kombination mit
anderen vorkehrungen eure aktionen in
essen nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit
hilfe verschiedener sicherheitschefs
könnt ihr so anonymität indes erhöhen zb
mit den integrierten knie wird dass alle
cookies und pop-ups blogbeitrag vorteil
als vbl ist dass ihr so tun können als
werden dort so könnt ihr zum beispiel
auch websites im internet zugreifen wie
im land ist nicht verfügbar deren ob
daheim oder im urlaub damit schlag der
zensur und der block ihm ein schnippchen
der flex und anderes training gibt die
ihre inhalte nur in den usa anbieten
wollen europa ausnutzen oder deutsches
internet fernsehen im ausland gurken mit
surf kein problem und das ist noch nicht
alles denn mit nur einem surf
kommentiert wirklich alle endgeräte fpl
registrieren handys notebooks oder sogar
euren smart tvs so und wenn ihr die
rabattpolitik de angibt bekommt ihr
vorschlag auch ein rabatt von 83%
obendrein den ersten drei monate gratis
dazu den links zu diesem angebot findet
ihr in der beschreibung unter diesem
video also nichts wie los besorgt euch
server und greift damit auch
gleichzeitig uns finanziell unter die
arme das könnt ihr übrigens auch direkt
mit hilfe des paypal sperrte links den
ich euch ebenfalls den die beschreibung
gepackt habe wir sind euch für jede
unterstützung dankbar denn damit hält er
uns auch in zukunft noch mehr und noch
besser videos zu liefern so und nun ab
nach amerika wo wir jetzt die beiden
oremex mal so richtig auseinander nehmen
werden
[Musik]
eine revolution mit angezogener
handbremse
joe biden präsidentschaft begann mit
einem wahren feuerwerk an aktivität oder
sollten wir besser sagen aktionismus
denn heute im sommer des jahres 2022 hat
die regierung im grunde nur drei dinge
erreicht erstens einen plan zur
bekämpfung der folgen der cobit lockdown
er allerdings etwas kleiner ausgefallen
ist als der von trump zweitens eine
erhöhung der staatsausgaben in den
nächsten zehn jahren um 530 milliarden
dollar und zwar durch anordnungen und
direktiven des präsidenten dieses geld
soll im rahmen des parlamentarischen
systems programmes armen menschen zu
gute kommen es handelt sich dabei um
zwei seit langem existierende gutschein
programm arbeitslose und arme menschen
können hierbei lebensmittelmarken
erhalten sobald die arbeitslosenhilfe
ausläuft das tut sie in den usa in der
regel nach etwa einem halben jahr und
drittens schließlich der inflation
reduction act dieses gesetz ist jedoch
nur ein abklatsch des ehemaligen bild
weckbecker plans
dieser sah nämlich in den heißesten
träume so manche demokraten bis zu 6
billionen us dollar für infrastruktur
und soziale wohltaten vor der inflation
reduction eck stellt nun den
minimalkompromiss darauf den man sich im
senat und im repräsentantenhaus einigen
konnte und so wurden aus billionen
milliarden
773 um genau zu sein und was soll mit
dem übrigen geld geschehen nun es geht
in die förderung von elektromobilität
saubere energien und dürrebekämpfung um
den klimawandel zu mildern 300
milliarden us-dollar sind vorgesehen um
haushaltslöcher zu stopfen es gibt
hilfen für die staatliche
krankenversicherung im volksmund
obamacare genannt und 80 millionen
kommen den steuerbehörden selbst zugute
diese sollen modernisiert und in die
lage versetzt werden noch effizienter
steuern eintreiben zu können
da werden sich die steuerzahler aber
freuen denn auf sie kommt es ja an um
das ganze programm zu finanzieren
man rechnet mit über 200 milliarden
us-dollar zusatzeinnahmen durch
ausweitung und verbesserung der
steuererhebung zum beispiel sollen große
firmen mit mehr als einer milliarde
us-dollar vorsteuergewinn mindestens 15
prozent auf ihre gewinne zahlen müssen
steuererleichterungen sollen hier also
wegfallen aktiengesellschaften zahlen
künftig eine einprozentige steuer auf
aktienrückkäufe und was kommt sonst noch
nun das war es im grunde und es ist
nicht viel wenn man bedenkt dass die
demokraten einmal ganz amerika erneuern
wollten so wie es roosevelt einst tat
nun muss man joe biden gegenüber jedoch
etwas fairness walten lassen denn er ist
nicht alleine schuld an dieser misere
[Musik]
viel mehr agieren die zentralbank fed
der präsident und ein teil des
kongresses unabhängig voneinander und
sie alle tragen einer mitschuld wenn es
allein nach beiden gänge während die
investitionen in harte infrastruktur wie
straßen brücken und vor allem
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge sowie
investitionen in grüne energien
wesentlich stärker ausgefallen aber bei
der demokratischen partei handelt es
sich nun mal immer mehr um ein
sammelsurium verschiedenster oft auch
ost ideologien die sich oft gegenseitig
das wasser abgraben und um unterstützung
für den ganz großen wurf zu bekommen
wurden viele unproduktive auf biologie
getriebene klientel-politik fußenden
maßnahmen eingeführt die in einem
eigenständigen gesetz entwurf nur schwer
durchsetzbar gewesen wären um die
unterstützung der republikaner zu
gewinnen wurde das ganze paket außerdem
stark zurechtgestutzt um die ausgaben
auf ein minimum zu beschränken das
ergebnis war also alles andere als
beides wunschtraum einer neuen
wirtschaftspolitik sondern das was der
kongress beschloss um eine mehrheit von
politikern zu besänftigen die etwas
brauchen um sich ihre wiederwahl zu
sichern ok jetzt werdet ihr natürlich
sagen sowas ist man ja gewohnt der
capital hill kreißte und gebar ein
mäuschen aber haltet euch fest denn die
mageren ergebnisse beiden politik im
eigenen land sind nur die spitze des
eisbergs denn schlimmeres bahnt sich an
viel viel schlimmeres ökonomen rechnen
damit dass eine rezession in den
kommenden monaten das land und seine
wirtschaft sehr hart treffen wird und
das in einer phase in der die
popularität des präsidenten sowieso
schon am boden ist die meisten
investoren und ökonomen sehen aufgrund
der zinserhöhungen der fed eine
rezession innerhalb eines jahres kommen
so eine cnbc umfrage das problem in
einer rezession wird jeder
wirtschaftspolitische fehler der
regierung die bürger doppelt so teuer
kommen und hundertfach mehr schmerzen
als in guten zeiten wenn genügend puffer
bereitstehen um fehltritte abzufedern
bislang haben wir nämlich nur aufgezählt
was beides regierung nicht geschafft hat
die preisfrage lautet jedoch viel mehr
was genau seine mannschaft in sachen
wirtschaftspolitik falsch gemacht hat
welche weichen ins abseits gestellt
wurden und welche auswirkungen für
amerika und die ganzen welt haben wird
also aufgepasst
[Musik]
was amerika nicht braucht
im grunde hat die regierung die lage der
us-wirtschaft falsch eingeschätzt und
von da an ging es nur noch bergab ein
beispiel ist beides corona hilfspaket
aus dem vorigen jahr man punkte sage und
schreibe 1,9 billionen us dollar in die
us wirtschaft die sich aber schon zu
großen teilen alleine von der pandemie
erholte die folge die geldspritzen oder
besser gesagt die geld dies kann wirkten
wie benzin dass man in einen brand names
inflation ist
[Musik]
das prinzip war einfach man gibt einfach
allen mehr geld und kein wunder dass die
preise dann steigen das hilfspaket sei
zum beispiel eine praktisch universelle
steuergutschrift von bis zu 300 dollar
pro monat und kind vor oder man
verteilte noch im frühjahr 2021 die
sogenannten stimulus schecks in höhe von
1400 dollar an singles und familien wenn
sie bestimmte einkommensgrenzen
unterschritten das sollte den
kurzfristigen konsum ankurbeln und
menschen in schwierigen zeiten helfen
dachte zumindest die us-regierung und
sie glaubte dass die bürger vor allem
die steuergutschriften ganz toll finden
würden und diese auch beibehalten könnte
die beiden an ist rationen war der
meinung dass diese initiative von den us
bürger mit offenen armen empfangen würde
so dass sie dauerhaft beibehalten könnte
aber dem war nicht so seht her nur einer
von drei amerikanern will dass die
erweiterten steuergutschriften für
kinder dauerhaft eingeführt werden das
hat natürlich dazu geführt dass die
republikaner nicht für eine verlängerung
über das erste jahr hinaus stimmten 2025
läuft das programm aus eine der
wichtigsten maßnahmen der regierung fand
also sehr wenig zustimmung sie erhöhte
aber die staatsschulden und heize die
inflation an auf werte um die acht bis
neun prozent
[Musik]
soziale wohltaten wie die eben erwähnten
werden immer damit begründet dass arme
amerikaner immer mehr ins hintertreffen
gerieten aber diese diagnose ist falsch
tatsächlich sind seit 2010 gerade die
einkommen der untersten lohngruppen am
stärksten gewachsen
noch mehr geld in diese richtung zu
werfen und neuer vorschriften
einzuführen bringt also nur wenig und es
mit blick auf die gesamte wirtschaft gar
schädlich und dann hätten wir noch das
thema unternehmenssteuern die beiden
regierung ist besessen davon die steuern
für unternehmen und angeblich auch für
die reichsten zu erhöhen zum beispiel
befürworte beiden die erhöhung der
körperschaftssteuer von 21 28 prozent
wenn das so kommt hätten die usa eine im
weltmaßstab sehr hohe steuerbelastung
für unternehmen die folge dies würde
investitionen der unternehmen bremsen
die gewinnmargen verringerten die sonst
so dynamische us wirtschaft verlangsamen
und das ist genau jene sache die man in
zeiten von inflation in kombination mit
einer kommenden rezession unbedingt
vermeiden sollte
[Musik]
denn wenn in amerika der staat den
unternehmen mehr geld in form von
steuern wegnimmt können diese nicht nur
weniger investieren ein end ist auch
seinen bürgern das hat mit der dortigen
anlieger kultur zu tun in den usa ist es
üblich dass die bürger ihre ersparnisse
in amerikanischen aktien anlegen sowohl
als direkte anlage als auch über fonds
oder rentenpläne die aktienquote hat in
den vergangenen zwei jahren sogar weiter
zugenommen laut einer gallup umfrage zur
wirtschafts- und persönlichen finanzen
im april gaben 58 prozent der amerikaner
an aktien zu besitzen das ist etwas mehr
als die 56 prozent aus dem jahr 2021 und
die 55 prozent aus dem jahr 2020 es ist
daher kein wunder dass das wahlvolk über
derartige steuerpläne nicht gerade
amüsiert ist wenn man sie mit der auch
in europa bekannten leier von den
reichen nehmen und den armen geben
begründet oft handelt es sich schlicht
um einfach um eine lüge oder ökonomische
inkompetenz der handelnden regierungen
kurz gesagt beiden hat eine
wirtschaftspolitik vorangetrieben die
auf öffentlichen ausgaben per
gießkannenprinzip setzte welche die
gesellschaft aber nur zum teil brauchte
das geld dazu sollte von
steuererhöhungen kommen die aber der
gesamten wirtschaft und gesellschaft
dann fehlen mit ihr deswegen schaden wir
haben es mit einer politik zu tun die
zur höchsten inflation der letzten 40
jahre geführt hat was wiederum die
us-zentralbank dazu gezwungen hat zu
reagieren mit zinserhöhungen
[Musik]
doch die kommen jetzt zum schlechtest
möglichen zeit für die wirtschaft die
vor einer rezession steht und eigentlich
niedrige zinsen und mehr finanzielle
spielräume bräuchte um sie zu überstehen
nun tritt jedoch das gegenteil davon ein
kredite werden teurer für unternehmen
steigen die finanzierungskosten da damit
gleichzeitig unternehmensanleihen für
anleger rentabler werden sinkt auch die
attraktivität von aktien so dass auch
die millionen amerikanischer
kleinanleger an ihre altersvorsorge
verlieren und ihren konsum einschränken
hoffnung besteht immerhin in einer fed
die zukünftige zinsschritte besonnen
angeht damit die wirtschaft nicht unter
hohen finanzierungskosten bleiben muss
und die rezession abgefedert werden kann
dafür muss die zentralbank jedoch mit
rückgrat auch gegenüber der aktuellen
beiden regierung agieren was er
eigentlich ihr job wäre die schnellen
zinsschritte in übersee haben auch einen
erheblichen effekt auf europa da die ezb
nicht in der gleichen geschwindigkeit
nachziehen kann dies würde den
hochverschuldeten südeuropäischen
staaten das genick brechen geht die
zinsschere zwischen den usa und dem
euroraum immer weiter auf dadurch fließt
immer mehr kapital aus europa nach
amerika ab und akkus des euros gegenüber
dem us dollar immer näher ab da viele
rohstoffe jedoch auf us dollar basis
gehandelt werden verteuern sie sich für
europäer deswegen noch mehr durch die
beiden oremex wurde also ein
dominoeffekt ausgelöst der die
inflationsraten auch in europa weiter an
heißt die ihr seht also liebe walter dix
zuschauer leidens unbeliebtheit speist
sich aus wirklich handfesten gründen
weil in der wirtschaftspolitik fehler
gemacht werden die der gesamten
wirtschaft schaden das erkennt auch der
amerikanische wähler trotz der tatsache
dass er durch steuererleichterungen oder
steam sex ich sag mal überspitzt kopiert
wird den amis scheint eine dynamische
wirtschaft mit chancen auf hohe gewinne
immer noch näher zu liegen als soziale
wohltaten eines paternalistischen
staates auf kosten des wachstums und ich
sag mal zum glück jetzt wie economy
stupid es kommt nun mal auf die
wirtschaft an du dummkopf bei diesem
wahlslogan ist mal ein demokrat
präsident geworden die beiden regierung
scheint dies allerdings vergessen zu
haben aber wir sind noch nicht fertig
mit den fehlern der beiden mx denn
oftmals geht deren agenda völlig an den
interessen weder vorbei
[Musik]
zum beispiel beim thema klimawandel und
umstieg auf saubere energie vor allem
auf diesen bereich haben es viele
projekte die demokraten abgesehen und
das ruft nicht gerade viel begeisterung
in der amerikanischen öffentlichkeit
hervor seht euch an nur ein prozent der
dlr nannten den klimawandel als
wichtigstes ziel für das land weiterhin
sorgen um inflation und wirtschaft das
ist bei den wählern unter 30 jahren der
gruppe von der man annimmt dass sie sich
am meisten das thema interessiert waren
es nur 3 prozent als vermeintlichen
beschleuniger der erhitzung hatten die
demokraten schnell einem ganz bestimmten
feind ausgemacht die öl und gasindustrie
und sobald beiden im oval office klassen
nahmen er ließ er eine
durchführungsverordnung nach der anderen
um den erzeugern fossile energieträger
das leben schwer zu machen und die
kosten in die höhe zu treiben
so wurden unter anderem die bohrungen im
aktiv national wildlife refuge gestoppt
und auch der bau der iss um experten mit
kanada abgesagt behörden sollten jetzt
auf biegen und brechen neue regeln zur
drosselung der ölförderung prüfen
versuchten gab bohrlizenzen
zurückzunehmen oder zu stoppen auch
steuervorteile für die branche wollte
man kann es wurde gar ein moratorium
verhängt in bezug auf die suche und
bohren nach erdöl um genau zu sein weil
die förderung und exploration von erdöl
fortan auf ländereien des bundes
ausgesetzt
gerade diese maßnahme das klima auffällt
sich zu wandeln ist fraglich sicher ist
jedoch dass man damit ganz
industriezweige der us-wirtschaft
bestrafte und dabei geht es nicht nur um
riesen wie exxon oder shell verordnung
die als big player derartige maßnahmen
verdauen können es geht auch ums
zulieferer des amerikanischen energie
sektor soll kleinere betreiber von
pipelines oder explorationsunternehmen
lagen viele jobs dran beiden maßnahmen
sollten auch eine klare botschaft an die
investoren es lohnt sich nicht hier geld
anzulegen die investitionen in neue
projekte und instandhaltung wurden total
abgewürgt ein großer fehler wie sich nun
herausstellt der nicht hätte sein müssen
wenn man die zusammenhänge zwischen
angebot nachfrage und preis beachtet
hätte als sich nämlich die wirtschaft
nach dem corona schock erholte stieg
auch die nachfrage nach öl und gas diese
nachfrage stieß aber auch ein
mittlerweile geringeres angebot denn man
hatte ja der energieindustrie
kapazitäten genommen und durch diesen
engpass müssen sich nun alle auf einmal
zwengel nicht nur die amis sondern auch
die ganze welt mitsamt europas
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist also kein wunder dass die preise
steigen und die verbraucher das jetzt
zahlen müssen sowohl in amerika als auch
in europa gegeben ist kam auch etwas
pech hinzu die russische invasion der
ukraine und der boykott russischen öls
heißen diese knappheit noch mehr an
jetzt kommen also mehrere effekte der
verknappung zusammen es ist der perfekte
sturm bzw die perfekte krise wohlgemerkt
eine krise zu dem verbraucher und die
wirtschaft mit ausnahme der öl und
gasindustrie denn sie wollten endeffekt
lässt die großen profit ab ohne es zuvor
eigentlich geplant zu haben aber auch
das ist jetzt viel wieder nicht recht
wegen der hohen gewinne der
energiebranche fordern demokraten einer
über gewinnabschöpfung steuer für diese
unternehmen sie beklagen die ölindustrie
würde das angebot künstlich verknappen
wohlgemerkt das sind oft dieselben leute
welche die innen und gasindustrie am
liebsten abschaffen wollten und dieser
branchen kapazitäten geraubt haben mit
der folge dass das angebot eben knapp
wurde und heute kapieren sie wieder
nicht dass eine über gewinnabschöpfung
steuer allen unternehmen und investoren
für die zukunft signalisieren würde
investiert bloß nicht in reserve
kapazitäten in der werbung euch deren
amortisierung kräftig versalzen nein das
ist wirklich eine wirtschaftspolitik die
an inkompetenz nicht zu überbieten ist
sie geht zu lasten der
leistungsfähigkeit der gesamten
wirtschaft der normalen familien und des
mittelstandes und das nehmen die
amerikaner ihrem präsidenten nun mal
verdammt übel was aber könnte die beiden
regierung jetzt tun und doch noch die
kurve zu kriegen und die lage zu
verbessern genau das sehen wir uns jetzt
mal an
das amerika wirklich bräuchte
ganz einfach gesagt amerika braucht mehr
investitionen in fassbare dinge wie
straßen brücken industrieanlagen
energieerzeugung also infrastruktur die
es seiner wirtschaft ermöglicht sich
frei zu entfalten
amerika braucht kein geld das in
unproduktive kanäle fließt amerika
braucht bessere öffentliche und private
investitionen in die richtigen dinge was
er damit meinen bei staatlichen
ausgabenprogrammen besteht oft eine
gefahr darin dass die regierung einfach
nur geld ausgibt aber nicht intelligent
investiert sieht das beispiel des die
modus checks oder steuergutschriften für
familien das problem es entsteht nun mal
keine neue straße auf der man schneller
zur arbeit kommt wenn man nur jedem
anwohner etwas mehr geld von der steuer
zurück gibt gut sie könnten mit den
geldscheinen ein paar schlaglöcher
füllen aber wäre dies wirklich eine
kluge investition
nun tatsächlich liegt ein großer teil
staatlicher gelder in sozialleistungen
oder unproduktive ausgaben das geht
zugegebenermaßen schon lange so und den
nicht erst unter beiden anstatt in
forschung oder infrastruktur wie einst
masters landesweites system oder den
super damit zu investieren wurden die
ausgaben größtenteils in den
sozialbereich die verteidigung und den
schuldendienst verlagert und dass es
verdammt unproduktiv zumindest aus
ökonomischer perspektive die regierung
verteilt zwar geld aber es gibt weniger
investitionen in infrastruktur forschung
das heißt in faktoren welche die bürger
des landes produktiver machen und die
wirtschaft konkurrenzfähiger gegenüber
der anderer länder das zeigt auch der
blick auf die blanken zahlen der anteil
der öffentlichen investitionen am bip
wird immer geringer
[Musik]
und zu allem überfluss in die
nettoinvestitionen der us unternehmen in
den usa seit fast 40 jahren rückläufig
eine erfolgreiche wirtschaftspolitik
hätten echte und vor allem bessere
investitionen des staates bedeutet die
den wirtschaftsleistung zu gute kommen
und eben keine beschneidung und
beschränkungen durch regulierung und
steuerlasten dies hätte auch ein
positives investitionsklima für
unternehmen geschaffen das sind alles
elemente eine angebotsorientierte
wirtschaftspolitik wie ökonomen sie
nennen doch beide nomics hat oft genau
das gegenteil davon getan und eine eher
nachfrage orientierte politik betrieben
und das mit den üblichen folgen höhere
staatsverschuldung inflation der
staatsquote in der wirtschaft und den
zufolge in effizientere strukturen aber
moment mal an dieser stelle müssen wir
kurz innehalten herr schlicht in amerika
gerade vollbeschäftigung mit einer
arbeitslosenquote von 3,5 prozent ist
doch gut wenn die menschen arbeit haben
oder nun arbeit ist fallen aber leider
schrumpfen die reallöhne aufgrund
derzeit grassierenden inflation was der
arbeiter für seine arbeit raus bekommt
ist also immer weniger wert und das
erklärt warum die stimmung der
verbraucher fast so schlecht ist wie der
großen krise 2008
trotz dessen dass der arbeitsmarkt
robust erscheint sind die verbraucher
skeptisch unzufrieden mit der politik
der regierung sie scheint zu verstehen
dass die beiden omis einschlag sind und
sie haben damit vollkommen recht denn
sollten diese die produktivität und
rentabilität der us-wirtschaft weiter in
den keller ziehen während die
unternehmen zu optimierungs und
restrukturierungsmaßnahmen gezwungen
sein oder aber pleite gehen auf jeden
fall ließe dies arbeitsplatzabbau zu den
gigantischen schulden der rezession und
der installation würde sich so noch die
arbeitslosigkeit hinzu gesellen eine
lang anhaltende krise die bis zu den
präsidentschaftswahlen 2024 wohl kaum zu
lösen sein und trump wie der ist weiße
haus spülen könnte aber an dieser stelle
seit erst mal an der reihe was ist eure
meinung zu beiden etwas politik glaubt
ihr dass beiden das steuer noch
herumreißen kann und erfolge erzielt
geht die amerikanische öffentlichkeit
sehr mit ihrem präsidenten um hat er
chancen 2024 wiedergewählt zu werden und
wird die us-wirtschaft wieder zu ihrer
gewohnten dynamik wieder finden und wie
immer sind wir auf eure angeregte
diskussion schon hochgradig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video ist was
gebracht habe jetzt gelernt habt fast
jahr gibt es gesang leib dass man
freunde und hat es nicht so mit
glöckchen mit keines unserer videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich wollen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine spende von euch
mit uns hält dieses projekt macht dazu
führen den paper link dazu findet ihr in
der beschreibung mit dem video was gut
und bis bald
[Musik]